prêté par troyes accueille jean luc
mélenchon à quelques heures d'une
échéance cruciale avec un grèce bien sûr
proche désormais du défaut de paiement
la sphère de quelques heures pour ce
soir sur les quais mélenchon et merci
d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
nous sommes aussi à quelques jours du
référendum en grèce oui non on connaît
votre butin évidemment si vous votiez
dimanche
non non on va évoquer bien sûr dès le
début de cette émission la crise qui
touche et menace toute la zone euro nous
parlons également du danger terroriste
le gouvernement que vous critiquez sur
tous les sujets en fait ils assez jean
luc mélenchon nous parlerons également
de votre ambition pour 2017 avec katell
prigent et avec perrine tarneaud nous
aborderons d'autres sujets sur lequel on
a envie de vous interroger également
comme l'espionnage américain des
présidents français mais également de
tout le cac40 ou encore on a envie
d'avoir votre sentiment sur ce que dans
l'appel l'ubs et risation de l'économie
en france comme partout dans le monde
en fait déjà en fait les sujets d'abord
bien sûr la grèce et le danger quand
même d'un saut dans l'inconnu ce danger
vous voulez le conjuré avec mélenchon
certains estiment que la gauche radicale
là bas comme ailleurs veut en faire
faire sauter la zone euro non là alors
ça c'est un mauvaise évaluation de la
situation
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire sauter
la zone euro peut-être et la planète
financière parce que ceux qui croient
que tout ça va s'arrêter aux portes de
la grèce se trompe ce qui va se produire
en grèce va avoir un impact sur toute la
zone euro et l'impact sur la zone euro
on aura sur toute la planète financière
nous sautons dans le guide mais je
compte gérer ce danger et et je ne vais
pas vous pouvez pas faire dix mille
démonstration juste une
ce soir il y aurait des fous de paiement
pourquoi parce que la grèce ne pourrait
pas rembourser 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros qu'elle doit au fmi on est
d'accord
or la banque centrale européenne a dans
ses coffres 1 milliard 900 millions
d'euros c'est à dire 400 millions de
plus que nécessaire qui appartiennent à
la grèce car ce sont des dividendes que
la banque centrale européenne tous sur
les titres de la dette grecque à la
racheter aux banques privées autrement
dit
l'argent qui est dû ce soir pourrait
être versé directement de la banque
centrale européenne au fmi il n'y aurait
pas de défaut par conséquent on voit à
cet exemple précis aujourd'hui que ce
qui se passe est un coup d'état
financier parce que les dirigeants de
l'eurogroupe ont pensé que comme
d'habitude le dirigeant grec céderait et
d'ailleurs vous savez que toute la
presse française n'a cessé de dire ah
ben ça y est tu prince a capitulé et
ensuite cramer y avait des signes
encourageants qui l'aiderait cède encore
si vous avez les signes encourageants ce
qui n'était nullement à l'afp josette
avons quand même sur l'expression vous
venait d'utiliser
vous parlez d'un coup d'état financier
espère que vous estimez vous nous dites
que les dirigeants européens
oui veulent à plus ou moins court très
embêté chérasse en le mettant dans une
situation de 2 comment dire de faillite
politique parce que à côté de la
faillite financière
il y aurait la faillite politique la
faillite politique ça consiste à lui
faire signer un mémorandum alors qu'il a
été élu pour faire le contraire surtout
que jean-michel il faut bien que vous
compreniez ça monsieur grossir c'est
très important c'est que dans ce que
propose l'europe
il n'y a aucune aide pour la grèce il
n'y en a pas un qui après un euro qui va
dans la grèce là mais c'est pas ce que
dit par exemple aujourd'hui michel
sabords j'arrive on attendait avant de
répéter ce que les hôtes ont dit toute
la joie mais je ne vous ai d'ailleurs sa
comparse négociations laissez moi moi
dire mon point de vue a créé ensuite
vous pourrez demander à d'autres ce
qu'il pense de ce que je suis en train
de dire au lieu de faire le contraire
donc aujourd'hui le soi disant plan
daide né de rien du tout il s'agit de
donner 15 milliards à la grèce d'ici à
novembre prochain sans régler le
problème du reste de la dette d'accor or
les grèves ils m'écoutent et fera qu'on
en sorte un jour de cette histoire de
dette bien 15 milliards ces 15 milliards
seront versées en tranches et chaque
mois la grèce recevra un petit goût si
elle a été sage
à quoi vont servir ces virements à quoi
jean michel rochât à quoi ça a créé des
routes à offrir dit non uniquement à
rembourser les organismes financiers que
sont le fmi la banque centrale
européenne et le mécanisme européen de
stabilité mesure devait d'être
solidarité dans les dernières n'y a pas
l'ombre d'une trace d'un commencement de
solidarité c'est un étranglement
méthodique systématique de la grèce qui
est entrepris par leur groupe pour faire
un exemple de manière à ce que les
peuples et peur d'une catastrophe
financière dans leurs progrès et ces
gens là viennent de se prendre à leurs
hallucinations
parce qu'ils ont cru qu'ils
procéderaient et que maintenant ils sont
devant une impasse totale mais si prince
ne cède pas jean luc mélenchon
ce serait faire un exemple comme vous
dites à notre propre détriment vous le
reconnaissez vous même
on entrerait dans une enceinte saut dans
l'inconnu mais pas toute la zone euro de
quoi et bien est ce que tu es si la
grèce par exemple sont des fous par
exemple messieurs vous ne voyez pas
c'est que ces gens étaient persuadés
madame merkel monsieur chat aux bleus un
monsieur hollande ne se sera pas et est
perçu à dire que tu chies procéderait
toute la presse leur disais que tu chies
prince avait déjà cédé et n'ont jamais
écouté ce que des gens comme moi disait
et c'était sans surprise quand même
puisque je les ai annoncé avant puisque
la question du référendum est posée en
grèce depuis le début du mois de juin
ils n'en ont tenu aucun compte ils ont
cru à leur propre propagande et
maintenant il se trouvait au pied du mur
d'une catastrophe que eux sont en train
de déclencher tout ce qui se passe là
nous l'avions annoncé les uns les autres
chacun dans nos pays respectifs
ce qui est en train de faire qui chipera
c'est ce que j'avais dit je le ferai
moi-même dans le référendum
oui alors écoutez moi pas seulement le
référendum d'abord la discussion nous
pouvons régler tout ce problème d'un
trait de plume
je sais que c'est compliqué à comprendre
parce que c'est de la technique mais
tout ça c'est des jeux d'écriture si
demain on décide que la dette grecque
est étalé sur 40 ans ou sur 100 ans
chaque institution qui possède des
titres de la dette grecque ne n'est pas
condamnée à effacer ses titres de son
bilan donc les bilans reste en équilibre
et nous les français à travers le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
nous ne sommes pas appelés à verser 40
milliards et les allemands ne sont pas à
perdre à verser 60 milliards et tout le
monde s'en sort et la grèce a une
nouvelle respiration dans les ag à
verser les milliards
mais j'aime mais non jean michel ruols
je ne comprenais pas comment ça se passe
ça ne se passe pas du tout comme ça on a
donné des milliards pour payer des
tranches qui était déjà dû il faut
maintenant donner une nouvelle chance à
la grèce comme on l'a donnée à
l'allemagne en 1953 lorsqu'elle avait
été dévastée par l'irresponsabilité des
dirigeants nazis et des gouvernements
précédente
vous ne pouvez pas content
le peuple grec a payé jusqu'à la nuit
des temps une dette en se privant de
tout ça c'est une idée qui a beaucoup
progressé vous l'avez noté jean luc
mélenchon dans la cour quand même
monsieur strauss kahn qui dit comme moi
alors si un échec si un échec demain
vous diriez que c'est aussi une terrible
défaite par exemple pour christine
lagarde pour la réputation du fmi pour
angela merkel
pourtant des regards de la garda qui
attendait bon vous parliez de madame
lagarde reste en mer phone qui est cette
femme
celle qui a donné 4 400 millions à tapie
celle qui a donné un milliard sept à la
société générale
sans même vérifier si kerviel avait bien
perdu là samedi et c'est elle qui lui a
donné des leçons de bonne gestion
cette femme qui ose dire je vais me
réunir avec des adultes dans la pièce
mais qui elle est celle là donc ces gens
sont des dirigeants du vieux monde une
élite une petite élite qui vit en prêt
la crise de confiance aujourd'hui dans
la zone euro par exemple nous sommes
tous liés par les obligations il est
drôle ont payé de la zone
bien sûr il est temps et alors ce sont
des pouvoirs alors qui faites vous
confiance mais c'est pas parce que moi
j'ai posé la question mais la question
ne se pose pas comme ça la question se
pose qui a un ensemble de pays se
sentent ils solidaires les uns des
autres et pour quoi faire
bien voilà c'est tout à partir de là
monsieur le petit prince qui aurait pu
ne penser qu'à la grèce a demandé qu'ils
aient une discussion globale qui n'a pas
eu une discussion globale qu'il essayait
de tirer son pays d'affaires je pense
que le coupable dans cette histoire le
plus grand coupable c'est françois
hollande car lui il a été élu écoutez
moi il a été élu en disant qu'il
renégocie ray le traité budgétaire c'est
le traité budgétaire qui impose à tous
les pays
la règle d'or qui impose aujourd'hui à
la grèce alors qu'elle est exemple alors
qu'elle est exemplaire alors qu'elle
n'en peut plus on lui demande de force
un excédent primaire c'est à dire avant
d'avoir payé des intérêts de la dette
il faut qu'elle dégage 1% de d'excédent
sur son budget mais même nous les
français nous ne faisons pas ça toutes
ces rayons été inventé et mis en place
dans le trailer jetair françois hollande
a dit qu'il devait leur ont négocié
c'était la puissance de la france la
france et 18 % du pib de l'union
européenne 22 % comme la pauvre grèce
et qu'at-il fait rien il est donc le
premier coupable
à chaque étape tout le monde s'est
tourné vers lui moi même je suis encore
à l'éthique lui qu'un modeste
protagonistes de la scène française
je suis allé le voir et je lui ai
personnellement pour lui
tu ne peux pas laisser faire ça nous
sommes en train de défendre
l'indépendance de la france à la
frontière grecque car les suivants c'est
nous alors il y aura peut-être les
espagnols alors d'amo expliquez nous
comment le nom s'ils l'emportent
dimanche pourrait être un accélérateur
pour la négociation elle dit d'accord le
premier ministre et si prince sa
dernière allocution télévisée oui mais
peut-être que l'on peut espérer que le
nom du peuple grec fasse réfléchir tous
les autres qui sont des démocrates en
principe dont ils ont du respect pour
les décisions du peuple qui constitue
l'union européenne parce que déjà ils
ont fait beaucoup de violence pour les
accuser de vouloir faire un coup d'état
côté des financiers oui et alors la
réponse c'est le référendum
donc après le référendum ça continue
comme avant à votre avis madame merkel
ce chat aux bleus monsieur hollande vont
continuer comme un vague à les payer et
pays et eia ils pourront plus dire allez
payer puisque personne ne paiera
résultat ils vont se retrouver avec un
euro assis sur une géographie politique
qui change
imaginez vous vous êtes un chinois c'est
le cas aujourd'hui de la république
populaire du signal à 25% de ses avoirs
en euros et vous allez leur dire
tranquillement ben écoutez la géographie
à changer ce pays n'y ait plus avait
peut-être que demain les irlandais n'y
seront plus durement que ce soit les
espagnols si vous avez beaucoup d'euros
vous avez une idée c'est vous
débarrasser d'un argent pareil donc
personne ne sait ce qu'il voudra demain
donc il ya un risque de contamination
pour l'europe en dans un premier temps
nous va bien rigoler les français parce
que plus l'euro baisse mieux se placent
leurs marchandises sur le monde mais on
rigolera pas longtemps parce que des
gens vont craquer tout le long de la
chaîne vous allez avoir des banques
monsieur grosse sueur imaginez vous que
vous avez vous comme ça dans vos
économies vous avez deux ou trois
actions d'une banque
eh ben je vous recommande une chose
dépêchez vous d'aller les vendre parce
que il se trouve que quand on proclame
on met un pays en faillite comme ça a
été le cas pour chypre on a obligé les
actionnaires des banques
et c'est bien normal à payer une partie
de la faillite donc quand vous avez un
type bancaire
eh bien vous le vendez ses entrées ce
qui est en train de se passer dont vous
décapitaliser les banques car qui veut
acheter les titres pourris d'une banque
en danger personne donc on voit comment
la contamination pour avoir lu ceci et
l'exclusive responsabilité du
gouvernement allemand qui dirige
aujourd'hui l'europe et de françois
hollande qui n'a rien dit et qui s'est
réveillée encore une fois dix fois trop
tard alors voilà qui est dit sur la
grèce avant le dernier on attendait sur
la grèce
elle tous ceux qui m'écoutent à venir
manifester avec les syndicats jeudi à
18h à la bastille manifestation de
soutien pour le nombre on parle du
danger terroriste
1 la grèce ans et c'est d'ailleurs une
porte d'entrée que certains de quoi juge
menaçante pour certains d'infiltration
en europe je ne parle pas des migrants
évidemment ou des réfugiés jean luc
mélenchon anglais et ils sont tous les
régimes et et par la grâce d'un coup sûr
malheur tout est mis en oeuvre pour
assurer la sécurité des français assure
manuel valls aujourd'hui après l'odieuse
attentats dans l'isère est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
quand j'en suis certain je pense pas
qu'il ya un responsable politique dans
ce pays qui traite cette question la
légère qui s'en fichent où tu ne fais
pas tout ce qu'il peut et donc je pense
qu'il ya certaines circonstances où il
faut savoir serrer les coudes
raisonnablement car l'objectif des
terroristes est quoi cette chaire peur
si nous nous disputons entre nous et
nous commencions à dire ah bah rien et c
c'est la pagaille et cetera ils ont
gagné ça veut dire que en effet on doit
tous avoir peur donc ceux qui essaye de
déstabiliser sur un sujet pareil perdre
leur temps maintenant ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut approuver du coup ça c'est là
la rouerie du ps est tout le temps la
même chose quand vous leur dites un
compliment gros comme ça ils vous
prennent le bras et le reste avant alors
vous êtes d'accord avec la loi
renseignements non la loi renseignement
ne sert à rien sinon à abaisser notre
démocratie c'est stupide de faire un
patriot act aucune valeur ni sont en
train d'y alors aujourd'hui on n ose en
attendant je ne suis pas d'accord pour
que la réplique au gouvernement ça soit
de le mettre en cause
sur la période après lequel ils
laisseraient faire j'espère au moins que
le gouvernement soutenait également
manuel valls qui aujourd'hui dans un
soutien personnes sur le lac et ce type
d'attaqué d'accord alors est-ce qu'il
faut s'alarmer aussi du danger
salafistes en france le premier est
toujours lui a dit qu'il y a 10 à 15000
salafistes dans notre pays et c'est ils
sont dans l'antichambre du terrorisme il
évoque la dissolution de certaines
associations qui pourraient soutenir les
visées jihadistes
et les mosquées des mosquées a longtemps
dit vous non mais je pense que tout ça
n'est pas n'est pas raisonnable le
salafisme est une branche de l'islam
extrêmement rigoriste et à mes yeux
assez discutable mais pour autant vous
n'allez pas faire de chaque salle
assiste un terroriste qui va tuer en
plein carême ou qui va approuver une
bombe dans une dans une mosquée parce
que c'est ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière le moment où valsent a trouvé
intelligent de parler de guerre des
civilisations ce qui est absurde qu'est
la vieille théorie nord américaine de la
guerre des civilisations
c'est précisément longue ça s'applique
pas puisque précisément les bons gros
éclaté dans une mosquée est dans un pays
musulman comme la tunisie enfin pelli
dans tel ou tel à la religion et il est
également une référence nous n'obtenons
la constitution laïque qui l'ont adoptée
par conséquent on voit bien que ça n'a
rien à voir avec un choc des
civilisations à kout on se calme la
grèce a pas une guerre contre notre
civilisation nous surprenons c'est une
guerre entre puissances régionales entre
différentes branches de l'islam qui sont
représentés par différentes puissances
régionales qui se font la guerre entre
elles pour contrôler le moyen orient
mais monsieur grossiord ça a toujours
été comme ça la lutte entre catholiques
et protestants en france la ligue du duc
de guise
elle était directement payées par les
espagnols et le roi de france essayait
de se faufiler entre les espagnols et
les grands seigneurs protestant de
d'allemagne les guerres de religions
n'ont jamais eu d'autre fondement que
les intérêts géopolitiques
je ne mets pas la naïveté de croire que
les troupes qui s'affrontent sur le sol
voient leurs armes tomber du ciel
leur véhicule arriver tout seul non
quelqu'un paye et je trouve quand même
un peu énorme que l'on fasse un procès
aux salafistes qui se trouvent en france
je ne sais pas combien ils sont nissan a
vraiment 15min qu'elle aurait à l'esprit
quand on s'en va les soutenir dans leur
propre pays là où ils gouvernent et où
on fait des affaires avec eux tout ça
n'est pas très sérieux
ça excite les gens les uns contre les
autres maintenant s'il y a des
associations et s'il y a des mosquées où
l'on près il ya un an
selon press la désobéissance à la loi
républicaine
il faut châtier durement et c'est vrai
pour toutes les religions
qu'at-elle président de la ffa
maintenant nous rejoindre pour évoquer
jean luc mélenchon votre votre travail
en vue de 2017 à votre mot a aussitôt
inquiétée à l'elysée on en cherche ans
et à éviter la concurrence à gauche pour
espérer
d'abord une qualification pour le second
tour de la présidentielle quand un calme
et à la peine dans tous les sondages
d'opinion comment françois hollande
peut-il envisager de se qualifier pour
le
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
parmi les proches du chef de l'état on
en appelle à la responsabilité des
candidats à gauche on verra bien qui
candidat dans un premier temps et puis
je crois que aux uns et aux autres
rappelons-nous 2002 on l'a connu on sait
ce qui s'est passé donc dans la période
dans laquelle on y reste bien ancré à
gauche
mais avant tout pour faire gagner la
gauche à la candidature de jean-luc est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie que ce les
côtoyer pendant longtemps au parti à ce
jour je n'ai pas vu faire acte de
candidature
donc je pense que chaque chose en son
temps c'est un homme de gauche donc je
ne crois pas demain parce qu'aujourd'hui
que nous mettons position que la gauche
perde potentiellement élections malgré
les frondeurs et le succès de podemos en
espagne en france aucune alternative à
gauche du ps n'émerge des élus frondeurs
viennent de quitter le parti socialiste
mais n'entendent pas pour autant
rejoindre la gauche de la gauche
à gauche le parti socialiste si je suis
là c'est qu'il ya vraiment des problèmes
au parti socialiste
les écologistes sont totalement divisée
nouvelle donne on voit que
souffre énormément aussi et puis le
front de gauche on voit bien
malheureusement c'est un constat stagne
voire des centaines et ses milliers de
je dirais de messages que j'ai reçus
depuis la semaine dernière
le citoyen qui ne se reconnaissent plus
dans les partis politiques
je crois que mais je crois que d'abord
j'avais pas l'intention de le faire mais
il n'y comprendrait même pas que je
quitte un parti politique pour adhérer à
un autre dans la foulée dépasser les
parties et rassembler le plus largement
possible au sein d'une nouvelle
formation avec un risque pour la gauche
radicale faire gagner la droite jean luc
mélenchon avait déjà réalisé un score à
deux chiffres en 2012 que ne veut pas
françois hollande c'était une
multiplication des candidatures à gauche
s'il y en a une sur laquelle on peut
s'appuyer
ça peut le favoriser en 2012 il faut pas
il faut pas oublier que françois
hollande a profité des 11 % de jean luc
mélenchon s'il françois hollande ne peut
sans doute rien faire contre la
candidature de jean-luc mélenchon
tout est mis en oeuvre pour éviter celle
de cécile duflot en 2017
voilà qu'à telle pression nous a rejoint
aux questions à jean luc mélenchon tout
premiers simples 2010 est ou serait
candidat je sais pas vous avez dit au
monde je dois travailler comme si
j'allais devoir être qu'en ce sens je
tombe je ne sais pas je sais que je le
cas échéant je peux l'être je sais le
faire avait déjà fait bon elle je me
prépare parce que c'est une épreuve
physique et une épreuve intellectuel de
haut niveau parce qu'il faut être à jour
de tous ces dossiers parce qu'il faut
donc je me prépare et je me rends
disponible et en même temps je ne me
lève pas tous les matins en me disant je
vais être candidat il ya tellement
d'étapes tellement de choses qui vont se
passer
regardez en vous rasant non non du tout
non non je comme je me rase j'évite de
me couper parce qu'après pour aller à la
télé c'est gênant mais le nom regardez
il ya tellement d'événements se
retrouvent après demain l'euro explose
vous voyez bien que tout cas c'est une
politique serait différente après après
demain les nord américains arrivent à
déclencher une guerre contre la russie
nous aurons un embrasement général de
toute l'europe ont peu plein de choses
peuvent se produire car le monde est
devenue très instable
si bien que ça n'a pas de sens de faire
des projections autrement qu'en se
rendant disponible
événement donc quoi qu'il arrive si on
devait avoir démarré là maintenant que
je serai prêt il va ce qui va rire mes
camarades te demande de le faire si mes
camarades mondial et qu'il faut le faire
ou si moi je décide je vais le faire
alors je serai prêt je n'ai jamais rien
de plus vous dites si mes camarades
disent il faut le faire camarades c'est
le front de gauche c'est le sait le sait
le front de gauche et puis tous ceux qui
trouveraient que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut qu'on fasse
vous savez moi j'ai la patience de des
gens qui ont la pratique de l'histoire
bon aujourd'hui il est de bon ton de on
ne peut plus faire une déclaration
politique s'en sortir le violon podemos
syriza et chacun croit que tout ça s'est
fait en quelques instants c'est pas vrai
j'ai rappelé supra se faisait 5 % quand
il ya en 2012 moi je venais de faire aux
% il y a ainsi il fait sa campagne
je me plais pour ça que je me rappelle
et ils passent de cinq à dix huit et
puis ça n'est que la fois d'après et
après de souffrances infinies
il est passé au point où on est quant à
à pablo iglesias et podemos il c'est une
scission disquaires dao nidal c'est à
dire l'équivalent du front de gauche est
il à son premier essai il fait vite %
pas plus et c'est les sondages qui
disent qu'il va faire 25 30 pourquoi
parce qu'à un moment donné une
perspective se dessine quand à moi
aujourd'hui puisque c'est moi qu'on sont
peut-être demain ça sera quelqu'un
d'autre mais quand on sonde sur mon nom
on tombe toujours sur le chiffre de 2012
c'est à dire 10 11
voilà dix contre dix compte bien la
dernière fois j'ai démarré à 3 alors
démarrer à 11 me fait pas peur j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un peu plus de ça
vous encore un an
évidemment que ça ma grosse encore âge
mais bien sûr il faut bien déjà utilisé
un mois des ressources
je ne peux pas simplement rester aux
appréciations de gens qui de toute façon
n'ont jamais été avec nous je veux bien
celui ci disent le front de gauche je
stagne les lilas et des temps le front
gauche à faire quelque chose non du
temps ils voter les lois et ils
passaient leur temps à dire que le front
de gauche divisée et le tout ce par
exemple que les verts disent aujourd'hui
après avoir dit une chose puis ensuite
le contraire qui ensuite encore une
autre et d'hilda on ne peut pas parce
que il ya un problème il y avait déjà un
problème en 2012 puisqu'il y avait
madame eva joly est ensuite
l'éparpillement des candidatures mais
c'était déjà le cas en 2012
il y avait à npa il y avait un lutte
ouvrière
il y avait il y avait donc ça a toujours
été ça m'a fort ça a été un moment
de par la l'enthousiaste d'emporter de
dire bah voila je présente une synthèse
république socialisme écologie je pense
que c'est la bonne synthèse c'est la
synthèse du 21e siècle après eh bien
nous verrons ce sont
il faut avoir la patience et comprendre
que la politique est un art de
réalisation ce sont les opportunités
qu'il faut savoir saisir pour changer le
monde et moi je pense que nous avons une
bonne chance en 2017 nous ce qu'on
appelle l'autre gauche oui nous avons
une bonne cliente on a quand même
l'impression que l'autre gauche comme
vous dites est quand même divisée vous
avez quelques soucis avec le pc ou sein
du front de gauche
vous avez tenté un rapprochement avec
cécile duflot qui vous a fait une fin de
non-recevoir au bout de quelques
semaines n'ont pas bon ce ne soit pas du
tout passé comme ça d'abord qu'il ait
des discussions dans le front de gauche
sinon j'en ai pas vous dire yadav on le
dit quand même
mélenchon c'est le gourou personne à
droite critique et monsieur je suis le
seul à qui on jette des pierres du début
à la fin de l'année vous m'avez jamais
entendu une fois critiquer les autres
mais par contre des critiques sur moi
d'ailleurs vous avez l'habitude et les
4/5 personnes qui viendront en
permanence témoigner de mon caractère
détestable
comme si c'était une découverte en ce
qui concerne les verts c'est pas moi qui
ai fait partir le signe du snow du
gouvernement tout de même c'est elle qui
est partie alors appartements et sort du
gouvernement
elle se pose une question que n'importe
quel responsable politique se pose
comment construire une majorité
différente de celle que je viens de
citer
mais elle elle veut tout à la fois et
dans la majorité dans le gouvernement
hors du gouvernement
avec le front de gauche sans lui et ce
n'est pas possible
quand on n'est pas dans le gouvernement
et qu'on est de gauche on appartient à
l'opposition de gauche et l'opposition
de gauche aujourd'hui c'est le front de
gauche plus nouvelle donne une députés
dans le parlement qui est madame
isabelle athar qui votent la plupart du
temps comme les députés du front de
gauche donc voilà la situation réelle ya
aucun lieu d'aller sabbath maintenant ce
qui change ce qui change beaucoup
c'est qu'entre temps la situation s'est
tellement dégradée sociale politique et
le reste les gens qui une telle méfiance
à l'égard de la politique justifiée car
le monde politique est rempli de menteur
et d'aventuriers et de combinards il
faut donc tout balayer la table au
absolument il faut une constituante je
les dis sur tous les tons vous ne vous
en sortirez pas si vous ne répondez pas
la france elle même à travers une
sixième république voilà ma proposition
c'est ça qui a changé
et les gens veulent s'en mêler donc moi
je pense que ce qu'il faut faire
ce sont des assemblées de citoyens et
une assemblée représentative
alors on voit l'appel à partir de là les
problèmes se régleront tout seul on
évoquait les 11% donc attribué dans les
sondages à jean luc mélenchon qui
l'encouragent
mais dont qui inquiète avait visé est ce
que effectivement une candidature du
front de gauche ou citoyenne il y aura
forcé visiblement une candidature
écologiste
est ce que ça ne va pas diviser et à
risque de marine le pen au second tour
oui bien sûr françois hollande peut se
retirer ne pas être candidat nous en
sommes d'accord et je m'occuperai du
reste alors non mais pourquoi on pose la
question à moi je dire qu'est-ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse qu'on aille après avoir
critiqué avec des raisons on n'a pas
critiqué par par mauvais caractère je
veux dire moi la vie était simple pour
moi si j'avais dit oui j'avais qu'à y
aller et j'aurais dis je ce ministère et
puis ça pour mon copain et puis sa peau
j'ai pas c'est pas ça que j'ai fait il
était honnête droit loyal alors après
avoir fait tout ça tout d'un coup je
vais arriver arrive devant les ennuis
finalement la loi macron à l'essai par
donné le refus du traité d'amitié à
perdre et vous aux gens qui lisent le
danger le pen le danger le pen peut se
se présente de la façon suivante quelle
est l'orientation alternative
voilà qu'est ce qu'on propose d'autres
français aujourd'hui on leur propose ou
hollande ou sarkozy ou le pen alors il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui disent
ah si c'est ça le menu je préfère le pen
pour envoyer tout le monde baladez vous
le savez comme moi c'est comme ça que ça
se passe bien alors à partir de là je
suis obligé de dire si nous faisons une
proposition on verra les gens aussi
viendront vers nous et on peut
parfaitement imaginer une situation dans
laquelle nous sommes capables de créer
cet élan est d'être présent au deuxième
tour moi j'y crois
moi j'y crois alors le faire et vous
nous dites que vos processeurs un
meilleur score que françois hollande oui
à vous me direz apparemment ça peut
aller à trop difficile mais ça demandera
beaucoup d'efforts mais oui c'est
possible vous qu'est ce que vous croyez
qu'il a que la partie va se
comme ça comme les comme elle est partie
en 2012 on recommence la même en 2017
avec les mêmes il ya un t-shirt pas du
tout entre temps les gens souffert les
gens ont ouvert les yeux se sont rendus
compte actions vous vous donnez
aujourd'hui madame le pen gagnante mais
pour l'instant on la donne qualifier au
deuxième tour qui a dit qu'elle allait
gagner
et puis je vous approfondi la question
vous croyez que réellement va amuser le
peuple français comme ça pendant des
années
dire le vrai problème c'est les
salafistes les mosquées les matins et
oubliez votre feuille de paye oublier
votre chômage
oubliez vos difficultés à trouver un
logement parlons des musulmans parce que
c'est le seul sujet qui a l'air
d'intéresser la classe politique mais
non ça durera pas les gens vont se
rendre compte progressivement que c'est
pas ça le sujet de leur vie et que quand
la vie est meilleure et en cas du
travail va tout le monde respire tout le
monde a envie d'être heureux tout le
monde a envie de partager
c'est quand il ya trois quignon de pain
pour 6 personnes que les gens commencent
à montrer les dents donc partageons et
les gens seront meilleures c'est mon
programme or ce qu'ils en donnent ils
l'auront
et sinon il rompt la guerre civile parce
que madame le pen c'est la guerre civile
vous le savez tous pourquoi on ne le dit
jamais madame le pen c'est la guerre
civile parce qu'elle va crier les
français elle va trier vous avez vu
abandonner leur carte d'identité à celui
ci en suite à cela elle elle veut elle
tri entre les français d'après leur
origine
d'après leur l'origine de leurs parents
combien d'années on va continuer à dire
à des gens s'ils sont un peu gros et il
faut vous intégrez combien de temps ça
va durer
avec ces gens qui sont nés en france et
moi on va me dire combien d'années
voulons intégrer qui était sénateur j'ai
été ministre
je suis la deuxième génération
d'immigration le premier ministre actuel
si on appliquait les consignes de madame
le pen qui serait même pas premier
ministre et monsieur sarkozy n'aurait
jamais été président de la république
combien de temps va durer ce cirque
ethniciste mona la question qui se pose
alors les français si vous voulez la
guerre civile ont voté madame le pen
nous devons nous incliner parce que
c'est le peuple qui fait l'histoire et
dames le pen justement qui s'est
déclarée candidate pour la région nord
pas de calais picardie
vous l'avez déjà affrontés sur ce
terrain là encore le ps appelle au
rassemblement derrière lui vous répondez
quoi leur faire barrage
on connaissait un barrage alors au début
c'est pour faire barrage à condition que
ce soit eux la tête de liste pour faire
la même politique qu'avant et soutenir
le gouvernement et bla bla bla bla c'est
à dire si nous nous rognons
si nous abandonnons tout ce à quoi nous
croyons alors nous aurons fait le
travail que les socialistes attendent de
nous et crois qu'ils vont gagner comme
ça nous migrol qui suffirait que nous
fassions l'erreur de mettre seulement un
pied sur leur pédalos et les gens
diraient ceux là c'est même plus en
dehors
jean christophe cambadélis considère qu
une désunion sur est incompréhensible
des coupables la raison qu'ils retirent
leurs listes et nous occupons nous de
présenter la nôtre et nous gagnerons
avec notre liste parce que nous nous
sommes des opposants sérieux nous avons
des propositions ambitieuses pour les
régions et notamment pour des régions
qui sont marqués par la pauvreté avec
les écologistes parce que sandrine au
soupçon est aussi candidate dilma moi je
suis pour le rassemblement mais derrière
moi pourquoi pas il faut discuter mais
c'est plus facile avec les écologistes
sont pas au gouvernement
je peux vous donner plein d'exemples la
discussion a lieu parce qu'il ya ce
qu'il dit ya ce que dit cécile duflot
pièce qui se passe sur le terrain qui
n'a rien à voir en région midi pyrénées
languedoc roussillon la discussion a
commencé en région rhône alpes
la discussion a commencé nord pas de
calais picardie que la discussion a
commencé alors après évidemment tout le
monde veut être tête de liste pour moi
je vais en occupant c'est pas mon sujet
mais je vois que les choses sont bien
engagées et partout il ya des appels
citoyens et partout il ya des assemblées
citoyennes qui se met en place
alors ça va aussi passer sous les radars
mais vous allez le découvrir comme ça
sera lui dirai mur tant mieux comme ça
on nous à la paix avant mais ça a
commencé au départemental vous avez déjà
eu ces assemblées citoyennes est déjà eu
des listes et des rassemblements alors
j'ai lu dans la presse que je ne sais
quel stratège en peau de lapin à diable
comme ça n'a pas marché ils n'ont pas
daigné tout de suite non pas du tout de
suite la majorité et les places alors
bon va faire autre chose ça c'est le
zapping politique je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça et je pense que les
écologies de terrain eux qui sont dans
la mouise dans la réalité du combat
ils savent très bien que leur allié de
tous les jours céline philippe rondot
servi que qui sont dans les magnifiques
avec lui qui sont d'aller dans les
luttes et donc ces gens se connaissent
se pratique et ont le même goût de
mettre en mouvement quelque chose qu'ils
soient citoyens
petite question parler des assemblées
citoyennes vous avez le congrès de votre
parti le parti ce week-end j'ai lu que
ce serait peut-être votre dernier
discours au congrès du parti de naulleau
bah oui ça ce que la prochaine fois où
je serai président d'une fondation parce
que jacques évident qu'il ya eu je serai
président de la république en d2 en mai
montant à la tête du parti est finie
depuis la campagne présidentielle
martine billard a dirigé ensuite le
parti tout ça c'est la vérité
elle a pris tout sur son dos c'est à
dire un travail gigantesque
parce que nous sommes un petit parti et
nous avons tous les problèmes et tous
les défauts des grands partis et
quelques qualités que les autres n'ont
pas bon maintenant c'est un saut
générationnel qui est en train de se
faire d'un côté eric coquerel danielle
simonnet sont aux deux coordinateurs la
direction du parti je pense si les
camarades sud les conseils qui leur sont
donnés par les dirigeants sortants va
être considérablement rajeuni bon voilà
ça car je ne sais pas indispensable mon
oeuvre à moi vous savez c'est c'est le
rêve on dit c'est la phrase qui dit le
trion de disciples et la gloire du
maître j'ai participé a fondé ce parti
je veux moi mon bonheur c'est de le voir
comme le voir marcher tout seul se
passer de moi bon tant mieux
et c'est ça qui va se passer alors bon
on me donne quand même le dernier
discours de clôture
j'en suis très heureux et j'espère que
je vais annoncer des choses qui est en
augmentation et quel objet non mais je
fais beaucoup de choses en même temps
ils allaient finir par vous noyer dans
mes projets on va aller dernière partie
de l'émission
merci les champions avec perrine
tarneaud il serait question d'autres au
niger glory et jean luc mélenchon il
sera encore question de vous avec
perrine pas un instant mais d'abord le
petit reportage de tom tran huy non la
vie ça n'est pas que produire et s'ils
font moins de travail que nous produire
plus de richesses tant mieux 1992 tribun
déjà jean luc mélenchon connaît le ps
parker le jeune sénateur a même trempé
dans les guerres d'appareils quinze ans
plus tôt dans les années 70 il a
affronté la jeune adjointe au maire de
massy marie noëlle lienemann aujourd'hui
sénatrice et jean luc mélenchon est
arrivé à massy comme directeur du
cabinet du maire de massy pour s'opposer
à ma candidature aux élections
cantonales
il n'y a pas réussi j'ai dont est élu
conseiller général de massy jean luc
mélenchon a donc échoué à dézinguer son
adversaire mais il a gagné dans cet
affrontement une compagne de route pour
un temps mais au bout de 30 ans de bons
et loyaux services chez les socialistes
melançon a la bougeotte certains en
plaisant ils étaient trente ans sénateur
socialiste et d'un coup il se découvre
che guevara bon
d'autres parmi ses proches louent au
contraire son courage mélenchon a eu ce
courage de sortir d'un parti où il était
très longtemps où il était parlementaire
où il aura plus rester parlementaires
dont et prendre le risque
un risque calculé issue de son
observation attentive de la vie
politique qu'il avait effectivement une
très bonne connaissance des stratégies
d'appareils et puis en même temps il a
été très vite fascinée par l'efficacité
d'un homme comme françois mitterrand
elle est d'ailleurs mitterrand disait
avec un petit nombre de gens déterminés
on peut prendre on peut faire beaucoup
de choses et comme son modèle mitterrand
jean luc mélenchon est un homme cultivé
c'est un vrai intellectuel vraiment dans
le vrai sens du terme
comme pouvait l'être des gens comme jean
pierre chevènement ou voyages huppé où
ce sont des gens qui ont une vraie ou
bayrou qui ont une vraie culture havrais
pas grande culturel qui leur âme les
amène à avoir une vision aussi politique
historique se dire et comme tous ces
hommes jean luc mélenchon croit en son
destin un destin présidentiel
mais si sa personnalité continue à
séduire son ego est énervante ainsi
d'ennemi que ses amis de gauche ça ne
vous met pas en colère quand on vous
parle de votre ego au 18 pour nous au
sérieux et ça me blessait maintenant je
m'en fiche maintenant vous laisser
glisser la table la phrase était plus
terrible que ça parce que avec 100
personnes vous prenez ce pays et moi
j'étais quand même prétentieux je lui
dis ah bah si c'est que ça j'ai un
multiple et il me regarde et dit on doit
pas parler des mêmes voilà voilà
françois mitterrand en réalité
zoug la détermination joue un grand rôle
et nous sommes un peuple un peu
singulier c'est à dire à la fois nous
sommes la grande nation politique tout
le monde fait de la politique en france
au montant un taxi de l'eau glisse trop
de monde fait de la politique on commet
la grande nation politique on aime les
parties en même temps les détestent et
une tradition bonapartiste chez nous
avec la constitution qu'on a
bon moi je je je suis obligé de
reconnaître que la culture de la vème
république que c'est serré tendu alors
ça donne des ça donne des scènes
grotesques parce que chez moi par
exemple dans ma famille politique
dans ma famille personnelle alors gros
proche la personnalisation il avait
comme moi je peux faire et je vais pas
venir avec un masque je peux me cacher
non mais ceci dit vous avez aussi
beaucoup théoriser un peu le bruit et la
fureur des invectives et non mais ça
c'est une sas est une stratégie parce
que j'aime la pensée politique
construite cohérente
j'ai décrit la théorie de la révolution
citoyenne tout ça est très pensée et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas que moi
ce débat il a lieu dans toute la gauche
notamment il a eu dans toute la gauche
latino-américaine et vous envoyer les
résultats en europe parce que pablo
iglesias énigmes et redone qui est son
numéro 2 ou chip race ou l'allemand star
la fontaine ou combien d'autres tous
nous avons passé nos vingt dernières
années à tourner dans les mêmes réunions
les mêmes endroits avec les mêmes outils
en amérique latine on dirige 9
gouvernement est bon en europe
ça y est la vague est passé de ce côté
ci on va voir ce que ça donne mais ce
qui est très drôle si vous voulez les
latinos eux mêmes sont stupéfaits
pourquoi ce qui n'a pas marché en
amérique latine je parle des stratégies
d'ajustement structurel pourquoi les
gouvernements européens les appliques
c'est ça paraît fou à eux ça leur paraît
fou votre dans le reportage politique
l'épaisseur de la culture simple vernis
des oppositions c'est comme point commun
d'avoir un destin vous sentez un destin
au sens camusien albert camus je me
retourne je vois cette foule de faits
divers
et tout ça ce qu'on appelle après-coup
indistinct l'empereur auguste quand il
meurt quand tu meurs sa dernière phrase
c'est acta est fabula la pièce est jouée
vous connaissez la fin
donc nous avons tous un destin si nous
retournons et que nous voyons dans notre
vie une cohérence la mienne peut être de
manière excessive et qu'elle est habitée
par le combat politique et le rêve d'une
humanité accompli et d'une émancipation
et général j'ai connu quelques-uns de de
cette rédaction qui m'ont connu fort
jeune tenant des discours très voisin de
celui de l'espérance qui me portent
aujourd'hui encore alors en ce sens oui
et puis bon vous savez ce que c'est on
commence par être candidat et puis après
on finit par se sentir élu et que oui et
alors on dira que j'ai appris c'est une
véritable pédagogie pour moi c'est à
dire chaque fois qu'il ya un point je me
dis qu'est ce que je ferais si je
gouverner le pays comment je prendrais
et à force à force cela vous dépassez
des fois il faut se dire justement non
ça rend ça vous met en colère dit on
gens ce n'est pas ça qui devrait faire
mais pourquoi il n'a pas encore fait ça
et alors autour de moi on me dit n'être
pas de mettre dans cet état c'est normal
je l'espère ya un an après les élections
européennes vous mettiez un peu en
retrait de la ville
si vous en aviez marre un peu de ce tout
ce tintamarre politique médiatique c'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que là il ya eu un concours
de circonstance sur lequel maintenant je
peux m'exprimer et été assez malheureux
bon je suis un homme comme comme vous
êtes un homme comme vous êtes une femme
devant nos vies et dans ma vie se
produisait des événements qui
contrariait tu me contrarier et puis il
ya eu le début de la maladie de la
pierre et moi j'étais miné par sa mine
et et j'ai été minées jusqu'à ce qu'ils
meurent parce que je voyais mon camarade
mon cerveau en double s'enfoncer dans
dans la mort et ne rien pouvoir faire
bien des gens qu'on connaît cette
situation et ils comprennent peut-être
plus directement peut-être vous même
avez vous connu ça enfin vous et d'y
renoncer à la politique non non non mais
attendez là il ya un mauvais concours de
constant j'avais eu un coup de blues ce
jour là je réponds à quelqu'un qui
m'interrogent vous rendez compte de
l'événement
j'allais partir en vacances jeudi j'ai
envie de bâiller aux corneilles et de
rien faire
en vacances on va quand même pas
s'agiter comme des frénétiques et alors
cette affaire est devenue énorme et on
me voyait partir et tout lâcher c'est
vrai que j'avais un plan à l'esprit qui
a été lourdement contrarié par le
françois delapierre dont je me suis
réorganiser politiquement bien sûr une
fois honorer la mémoire de charles
pasqua c'est ce qu'a dit manuel valls
tout à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale
devant des députés qui l'a incité à se
mettre debout à gauche et droite
confondues
il a eu raison charles pasqua mérite cet
hommage ce qui n'est pas normal c'est
qu'un premier ministre à vis des députés
à faire quelque chose d'à séparation des
pouvoirs faisait que sous la troisième
république le seul fait qu'un ministre
applaudissent était constituée et est
considérée comme une tentative de coup
d'état
l'exécutif et le législatif sont
strictement séparés le premier ministre
n'a pas à enjoindre et député de faire
ceci c'est une inflation à l'invitation
à l'accompagner bon alors après le cap à
scott o'neill le connaît il est
extrêmement ambigu et il ya des parts
d'ombré départ de lumière les pardons je
les connais c'est un anticommunisme
féroce c'est la ferme annick oussékine
on penserait d'ailleurs après non plus
l'accusé personnellement d'avoir voulu
la mort de malik oussékine mêlant qu'il
est politiquement responsable et puis le
premier homme qui a touché au code de la
nationalité en france depuis pour tous
les pieds noirs aussi de pieds-noirs et
petit-fils de pieds noirs c'est un enfer
d'avoir des papiers d'identité
et puis la part de lumière c'est un
homme qui vient de la résistance c'est
un homme qui était habité par un
sentiment républicain et un trait tiers
indépendantiste français j'ai raconté
l'anecdote quand il avait expulsé 43
diplomate nord-américain et qu' il m'a
dit pas du tout j'ai sucé quarante trois
espions bon il s'est fait homme qui
était capable de tenir tête
1 et notamment ont nord-américain
variétés qui n'existe plus on devrait
s'inspirer aujourd'hui parce qu'on
apprend que la suite que l'espionnage
américain va bien au delà la serre
politicards ça touche aussi l économie
qu un les contrats économiques
ben moi je sais ce que je ferai à moi je
déclarer que d'abord je convoque
l'ambassadeur sous les députés français
les combes la convoque et elle vient pas
et dans ces conditions le président de
la république doit considérer que
l'ambassadeur des etats-unis en france
et persona non grata parce que ici c'est
la france qui commande et la france
commandes et les usages qui voudrait que
l'on soit des amis paraît-il alors qu'en
fait nous ne sommes pas des amis avec
les états unis d'amérique contrairement
aux apparences d'abord la prendre c'est
qu'il nous espionnent tout
poux sur tous les sujets parlait avec un
grand industriel moi ça m'arrive
régulièrement avec des industriels dit
les états unis et la chine font partie
des sujets de conversation de protection
non seulement le gouvernement ne sait
rien mais il est finalement dans la
gesticulation politique
en tout cas il est dans l'inaction c'est
pas la première je vous rappelle que
quand la sphère a éclaté de l'espionnage
en europe 1 on était au début de la
négociation du traité
sincèrement je suis pour qu'on arrête
immédiatement négocier des gens qui nous
espionnent bien donc ça c'est deuxième
point premier point madame
l'ambassadrice rentrer chez elle
deuxième point on stoppe les
négociations mais stoppé les
négociations s'étaient ce qu'avait dit
qu'il ferait françois hollande
la dernière fois et pour finir les
allemands dit non non on n'arrête pas
les négociations au contraire on les
commence il faut aller vite et françois
hollande l'a dit bon d'accord
donc si vous cédez une première fois à
tout vous connais vous cédé une première
fois vous montrer que ça n'a pas
d'importance
les autres continuent donc montré ferme
sur l'espionnage en a peut-être des
choses à se reprocher mais aussi en fait
la même chose pas avec les mêmes moyens
1 non non nous n'avons rien alors que
nous défendons et nous n'acceptons pas
que c'est une agression nous espionner
qu'est ce que vous en savez vous accuser
le gouvernement quelque chose de se
grossir non mais la vieillesse est
communément que tous les pays il ya des
rumeurs comme ça l'est alors moi je suis
responsable politique français donc je
pense que ce que font les services
secrets français légal et bien il
conforme à l'intérêt du pays et
l'intérêt de notre pays n'est pas
d'espionner tout le monde et n'importe
qui nous espionner ce qu'il est
nécessaire d'espionner et j'espère qu'on
expirmé américain puisque c'est le seul
moyen qu'on dit de se protéger de pardon
il ya quand même un point qui reste en
suspens c'est assange
oui vous allez vous poser la question
manuel valls a dit la question de son
asile politique en france ne se pose pas
vous le regrettez c'est à dire que cette
phrase est une phrase typique dans
socialiste à dire ça veut rien dire en
effet à 100 événements de la vie
politique à personne dit il n'est pas
réfugié politique
il est réfugié dans une ambassade dans
une fièvre incomplète
oui c'est allé rencontrer et il est là
parce que la suède qui voudraient lui
poser des questions le procureur suédois
pour une sombre histoire de moeurs
intérieur très discutable et lui à 100
et je suis tout à fait disposé à
répondre mais je demande la garantie
qu'on met culte à aux états unis
seraient radicalement
immédiatement mort et la suède refuse de
lui donner cette garantie donc manuel
valls devrait accueillir assange en
france et lui garantir qu'on leur mettra
pas aux états unis d'amérique de la même
manière nous devrions accueillir de ce
snowden qui est actuellement réfugié en
russie
pourquoi accueillir ces deux personnes
d'abord quand mesures de représailles à
l'égard d espionnage des états unis et
deuxièmement parce que ces deux
personnes ont rendu à signaler service à
notre patrie en nous permettant de
connaître et nous espionner donc s'il
voulait la nationalité française il
faudrait leur donner
je voulais vous poser une dernière qu'il
est d'accord je ne sais pas la question
je suis d'accord car le temps presse
hyper pop ne va pas avoir beaucoup le
temps de développer sur l'ubs et
risation ce qu'on appelle de la société
de l'économie
est ce qu'on peut dire que
libéralisation finalement c'est le
nouveau nom du libéralisme c'est
clairement le travail à la tâche mais je
ne veux pas chipoter ça je veux juste
dire une chose c'est pas juste que pour
permettre une chose comme celle là on
organise la ruine de braves gens parce
que ceux qui ont acheté leur licence de
taxi l'ont fait au prix il faut savoir
au prix de quels efforts ses amis
adorent la situation je crois quand on
nationalise par exemple on indemnise pas
d'accord avec ça mais c'est la loi
accorde donc on applique donc quand on
privatise et durs devraient aussi
indemniser ceux qui sont les victimes
des privatisations et dans ce cas là
j'avais les sens par l'état écoutez mais
sinon quoi alors vous êtes d'accord pour
dire qu'un jeune ou une personne qui a
mis de côté qui a travaillé toute sa vie
pour avoir une licence qui est de
contrebande qui est on l'a suggéré de le
faire on lui a dit c'est comme ça qu'il
faut faire monsieur soyez courageux
travail et vous aurez une retraite par
et tout d'un coup on lui dit vous pouvez
mourir j'en ai rien à faire c'est pas
normal c'est pas acceptable et je vous
garantis que si vous parlez avec les
gens moi je suis papa taxis contre
hubert ou hubert courseaux thani
je suis pour qu'on ne dépouille pas des
braves gens qui suis au travail
merci sur l'expansion merci perrine
c'est la fin de cette émission la
semaine prochaine c'est le président du
sénat gérard larcher qui sera l'invité
de trois par trois bonsoir a très vite
moi